انت عندما تاخذ قصيده قصيده
وتحولها الى مناخ بصري الى لوحه الذي
يفتنك هو المعنى ام
شكل القصيده
النص يحدد احيانا يجذبني ايقاع الحروف
يعني ايقاع الاحرف مثلا
الجيم والحاء مثل الهاء هيدي موجوده حتى
تعثر عليها في الروايات وفي النص الديني
وفي صحيح لكن بالشعر موجوده يعني لا نتفق
ان الشعر هو لغه اسماء من الروايه ومن اين
نص اخر كتجلي للغه يعني بالنسبه طبعا
تكثيف واختزال يعني فاذا الحرف ايضا الحرف
ايضا تجريد فهو تكثيف واختزال لكن احيانا
ياسرني المعنى اذهب بالمعنى لانه المثير
هو واحد والتجلي مختلف انت تشاعر تكتب
القصيده الاخر يكتب الروايه الاخر عمل
قطعه موسيقيه لكن انا احاول ان اتجه الى
الجوهر الى المثير نفسه يتجلى بعملي وهذا
اللي حدث مع ماغنوسن وحنان
وشعراء اخرين عندما راوا لوحتهم تجلت بشكل
عجيب غريب
قد لا تصدق انه الصوره
ذهنيه لي لهذا العمل لهذه القصيده هذا
الشكل
نوع من الاختراق عن طريق الحرف لكي
يؤلف عالم بصري موازي